y
bueno
algo que está muy bueno en este mundo es
que por suerte hay muchísimas maneras de
vivir
pero al menos en el contexto en el que
yo me creía y que creo que comparto con
varios de ustedes la felicidad es algo
que vamos a alcanzar cuando logremos
tachar varios ítems dentro de una lista
ser bellos hegemónicos tener una
vocación una carrera un buen trabajo
ganar buena guita poder viajar por el
mundo tener una casa propia y hasta
cumplir con el concepto de amor ideal
romántico y formar una familia y todas
estas ideas están relacionadas a un
concepto que por suerte ya varias
personas se encargaron de discutir qué
es la idea de éxito y por supuesto cada
uno de ustedes va a tener una idea muy
particular de lo que es ser exitoso y
eso está buenísimo pero del concepto que
yo estoy hablando es de ese que es como
un paquete cerrado con el que nos
criamos donde muchas veces la profesión
tiene más valor que las personas en
realidad y valoramos a alguien o lo
admiramos porque tiene guita o lleva
determinado estilo de vida y eso no
tiene que ver con que seamos medio
tontos es que en realidad la sociedad se
encargó de inculcarnos desde muy chicos
como vivir aquí en admirar y qué cosas
son valoradas casi universalmente
y a lo largo de la vida nos vamos
poniendo metas para ir tachando algunos
de los ítems dentro de esa lista y
corremos casi sin mirar al costado
porque estamos convencidos que de
cumplirlas en algún momento vamos a
empezar a disfrutar un poco
ahora qué pasa cuando más o menos vas
cumpliendo bien alguna de las metas que
te propusiste pero todo lo que sentís es
que estás viviendo la vida de alguien
más que seguramente esté muy contento
con todo eso pero a vos no te está
pasando absolutamente nada
bueno esto es un poco la historia de mi
vida mi nombre es hilda tengo 40 años
soy porteña muy porteña nací en buenos
aires y hace casi 7 años que vivo acá en
santa fe
en realidad vivo en rincón rodeada de
pájaros árboles tengo gallinas que ponen
huevos perros gatos y un sinfín de
bichos salvajes que están dando vueltas
por alrededor de la casa de hecho me
acostumbré hasta acá ranitas adentro de
la ducha para entrar a bañarme y si no
vivo llena de barro vivo llena de tierra
desde ahí hago muñecos de tela que se
venden en todo el país tengo mi estudio
taller adentro de un colectivo fuera de
línea que no tiene motor y lo dejé más o
menos estacionado en la parte de
adelante de mi casa
la verdad es que esa vida me encanta
vivo muy rústica mente y muy alejada de
todo pero en esto soy feliz
y los voy a ser honesta esto jamás fue
el sueño de mi vida hasta los 33 años
viví de una manera completamente
diferente a esta y no ocurrió que una
mañana me levanté y dije con valentía me
voy a vivir en la naturaleza y abandono
todo lamentablemente el camino que me
llevó hasta acá fue bastante menos
heroico que eso como les conté nació en
buenos aires y desde muy chiquita era
recontra curiosa muy interesada desde la
mecánica hasta la filosofía pasaba horas
encerrada en la biblioteca del barrio
leyendo todo lo que se me cruzaba el
alcance era una terrible mal alumna y
tuve una adolescencia bastante rebelde
cuando me tocó elegir una carrera por
motivos recontra altruistas y honorables
decidí estudiar medicina y me dediqué a
fondo a eso en paralelo mi necesidad de
independencia siempre fue muy fuerte y
mis viejos me inculcaron que era
imposible ser independiente si primero
no tenía una independencia económica así
que también a los 15 años empezó a
trabajar y trabaje de todo lo que en
contra en el camino que me permitiera
por un lado terminar el colegio y
después poder seguir estudiando
en uno de esos trabajos así medio
erráticos y más o menos por azar entré
en el call center de un banco en ese
banco y se carrera salir el call center
pasé por varias áreas me hice cargo de
sectores chiquitos al principio y cada
vez más grandes y para los 28 años era
jefe de un área estratégica con más de
70 personas a cargo un presupuesto de
millones y manejaba muchísimos proyectos
a la vez
por supuesto que dejé medicina no
imposible
en su lugar estudie logística después
hice un posgrado en la universidad de
tela y como mi curiosidad seguía siendo
gigante esta vez tenía disponible
económica y era independiente hice
cuánto curso taller y cosa me fue
pareciendo interesante hacer
artes oficios hasta séptimo en el de
veleros he participado como productora
ejecutiva de muchos proyectos de música
independiente
el trabajo era interesante sobre todo
muy desafiante y ganaba muy bien casi
diez veces más de lo que gano hoy no soy
pobre pero ganaba mucho y sé que otra
oficina muy bonita para esta altura casi
un mes de vacaciones y la disponibilidad
de viajar al lugar que se me diera la
gana
eso por un lado estaba bueno pero por
otro lado el precio que se paga por este
tipo de carreras es muy alto no
solamente trabajaba bajo muchísima
presión muchas veces traicionando a mis
propias convicciones y muchas veces sin
horario directamente sino que también
tenía un celular corporativo que sonaba
sin parar sin importar qué día fuera ni
dónde estuviera yo y dónde estaba salía
corriendo para juntar un equipo para ir
a resolver alguna contingencia
además de esto estaba repleta de
actividades tanto sociales como
culturales porque era una necesidad para
mí justificar que todo lo que hacía no
era únicamente trabajar pero lo cierto
es que cada actividad cada cosa en la
que me metía era más o menos una excusa
para poder descomprimir toda esa presión
y levantarme fresca la mañana siguiente
para seguir teniendo ese tan alto
rendimiento que necesitaba
además de ser muy capaz en estos puestos
seth existe que también poder manejar un
montón de habilidades blandas sutiles y
hasta políticas que te ponen a prueba y
te estresan además toda tu parte
emocional y personal
en resumen esa época de mi vida era
muchísima velocidad y muy intensa me di
la cabeza contra la pared una infinidad
de veces y también terminen formándome
muy mal
no tenía ganas de hacerme cargo de eso
por supuesto yo al médico y hacía todo
lo que había que hacer pero la verdad es
que era imposible negar que lo que
estaba pasando era que mi cuerpo me
gritaba en la cara que era momento de
parar que yo no podía seguir viendo
mucho más bajo este nivel de estrés
y no es que fuera una mina necia en
realidad era bastante lógico lo que me
pasaba tenía muchos años mucho esfuerzo
y mucha juventud invertida en esta
carrera además llegar a esos puestos
siendo mujer y siendo tan joven era casi
una hazaña
muchos años pasé convencida de que eso
que hacía todo lo que estaba dejando de
lado estaba bien que todo lo que estaba
sacrificando valía la pena lo único que
logré negando lo que estaba pasando fue
postergar un poco más el final y hacerlo
un toquecito más dramático
una noche volvía de trabajar después de
más de once horas de la oficina como era
lo habitual y semanas descansando muy
mal y mi cerebro se resiente
completamente me desperté algo que me
parecía que era un subte no estaba
segura no reconocía ni los carteles que
estaban ni en qué idioma estaban
escritos ni la ropa que tenía puesta no
sabía de dónde venía ni a dónde iba y
tampoco sabía la clave del teléfono que
tenía en la mano
fue medio difícil salir de esa pero la
mañana siguiente no me quedó otra que
presentar una licencia médica ahí que
era mi jefe y lo hice con tanta
vergüenza y llorando tanto que no lo
pude ni siquiera mirar a los ojos
tampoco puedes contar las cosas de mi
oficina ni decirle a las personas que
trabajaban conmigo que era lo que estaba
pasando y de hecho nunca más volví a
pasar ni por la venida de este edificio
es la regla pero no puedo creo
para ese momento sosa conocí a quien hoy
es sigue siendo mi pareja él era el tipo
menos ideal en el contexto en el que yo
vivía él era santafesino y vivía en
santa fe que eso para los porteños es un
montón tenía dos hijos que en mi vida
parecía un montón y además una vida muy
muy poco glamorosa
la decisión de venir nuestra santa fe no
me costó mucho en realidad tomé mi piano
las plantas del gato un poquito de ropa
en un bolso y me vine para acá superar
la vergüenza que sentía superar la
sensación de fracaso y recuperarme me
llevo bastante tiempo más
durante mi primer año en santa fe fui
viene de buenos aires- bastante seguido
era un poco tramposo eso porque estaba
acá y estaba allá
un poco tenía que resolver mis temas de
buenos aires- tenía que resolver mis
temas médicos y además tenía varias
propuestas de laburo para trabajar en
buenos aires para trabajar en otros
países y hasta para trabajar desde santa
fe viajando remotamente cada tanto
no podía hacerme cargo de ninguna de
todas esas propuestas yo estaba
absolutamente rota me largaba gerard si
se me caía un vaso y lo único que
necesitaba era estar un tiempo alejada
del mundo así que me encontraba en una
ciudad que no conocía sin ninguna de la
gente que habitualmente frecuentaba por
primera vez en 18 años sin trabajo y sin
tener la más pálida idea de lo que iba a
hacer era un misterio de eso
dentro de todo eso me lo pude tomar con
bastante bastante calma
en una de estas vueltas de buenos aires
me vine con los dos objetos más
ridículos que tenía guardados eran dos
cajas repletas de retazos de tela y yo
en mi vida había cocido más que un botón
a las apuradas yendo a laburar
eso y las telas siempre me había
parecido súper interesante y con los
años había estado coleccionando nunca
entendía para que cuando estas cajas
llegaron a santa fe lo primero que hice
fue un muñeco de tela y les recuerdo que
no sabía coser así que me costó bastante
y yo le tengo mucho cariño a su muñeco
pero no es muy bonito
la técnica me pareció súper interesante
y como tenía una enormidad de tiempo
libre me puse a investigar cómo era que
se hacían los muñecos y si les interesa
les cuento que es un proceso fascinante
para mí así que de este muñeco vino uno
vino otro algún momento me parecieron
que estaban lindos los subí a internet y
se empezaron a vender
en este principio hacer muñecos para mí
era como una terapia era parte de un
diálogo que estaba teniendo conmigo
misma muy necesario donde intentaba
entender que me había pasado en qué
situación estaba y quién había sido yo
podría conectar con mi origen con mi
infancia y sobre todo entender qué cosas
para mí eran importantes de verdad
el proyecto fue creciendo en la medida
que yo me iba pudiendo recuperar y
cuando creí que podía vivir de eso
agarré todo el conocimiento formal que
tenía en gestión y lo traté de amoldar
esa estructura tan pequeña que intentaba
estar crecer y entraron en juego un
montón de habilidades todas esas cosas
que había aprendido alguna vez y que no
sabía ni para qué me van a servir
estaban ahí conmigo y hasta recordé
cosas que quería totalmente olvidadas
todo eso entró en juego adquirí
habilidades nuevas y pude armar algo
casi desde la nada
eso me ayudó muchísimo a resignificar
eso que para mí había sido un fracaso y
sobre todo me permitió entender que
ahora tenía algo medio mágico entre las
manos que era la posibilidad de elegir
de qué manera iba a trabajar y esta vez
no era solamente para mi beneficio y
para mi tranquilidad personal era de
quién manera voy a empezar a trabajar y
me voy a volver a relacionar a un mundo
del que más o menos me había escapado
hoy con este proyecto no estoy sola
trabajo con una cooperativa de mujeres
que si son construidas de verdad y son
muy buenas a ellas yo me acerqué
contándoles que si quería seguir
creciendo necesitaba que otros empezaron
a sumarse lo que yo hacía y les fui
enseñando la técnica particular de hacer
muñecos y si bien ellos en un principio
creyeron que yo estaba totalmente loca y
que era imposible volver a reproducir
esas piezas chiquitas y tan llenas de
detalles después de varios meses estamos
fabricando toda la línea de producción
nosotras juntas
a esas no solo fui a enseñarles lo que
yo había aprendido sino que también
comparto con ellos todo lo que sé y
ellas hacen lo mismo conmigo entonces no
solamente generamos una relación
cliente-proveedor donde les pagó por el
laburo que hacen sino que entre nosotras
estamos compartiendo el trabajo y eso
para mí tiene muchísimo valor
también en el proceso de emprender
conocí a un montón de otros productores
y otros diseñadores y con ellos también
comparto con ellos consulto lo que se lo
que las dudas que tengo y les ayudo en
lo que creo que les puede ser útil
porque para mí la felicidad real es
compartida y el crecimiento de verdad
también lo debe ser
lo que yo hago para mí es un poco más
que hacer muñecos lindos aplicando algún
que otro criterio de eficiencia esta es
la manera que encontré por ahora de
relacionarme con un mundo que todavía me
sigue pareciendo bastante hostil
diseño muñecos desde la ternura y el
humor intento que todo el proceso esté
enmarcado en criterios que para mí sean
genuinos y sobre todo que construyan
realidades más amables y esto no tiene
que ver con que yo soy una persona
tierna y de la bondad pura no los voy a
engañar de hecho soy una persona
bastante ácida bastante pesimista y
bastante cruda con las cosas pero para
mí la ternura y la amabilidad son gestos
que busco con muchísima intencionalidad
son gestos disruptivos que creo que
pueden cambiar el mundo o al menos en mi
experiencia sé que el teatro cruel
deshumanizado y competitivo solo lleva a
pegarse la cabeza contra la pared
para mí la ternura no tiene nada que ver
con lo infantil ni con lo inocente ni
con lo débil para mí la ternura es un
acto de militancia que lo llevo adelante
todos los días porque como dijo alguna
vez también que para mí tiene mucho
valor
vivir sin militar por algo es vivir
únicamente para pagar cuentas
esto qué
yo estoy haciendo es intentar cambiar mi
vida yo me propuse vivir esta vez muy
honestamente primero conmigo y en la
medida que no lástima con los demás esto
que hice de abandonar todo una vida que
en este momento para mí fue una locura
terrible y todavía puede verse así o
quizás como un fracaso fue mi
oportunidad de vivir una vida de la que
me siento orgullosa y que finalmente
siento que es mía
hasta que no tengo muchas cosas en claro
no se crean todavía estoy intentando
entender lo que pasó lo que pasa que
pienso pero algo sí entendí que esto es
un camino que esto es una búsqueda que
no sé dónde me va a llevar porque en
realidad nada es definitivo también
entendí que nada nada de lo que nos
genere curiosidad en los que nos podamos
meter es en vano porque todo en algún
momento encuentra su lugar también sé
que ninguna experiencia a la que nos
metamos cuando la abandonamos pierde
sentido porque se re transforma en algo
diferente aprendí que la felicidad no
tiene nada que ver con listas que es
algo mucho más chiquito mucho más
cotidiano y por lo general lo tenemos a
más a mano de lo que pensamos y sobre
todo se ahora que es muy difícil
siquiera saber si sos feliz si primero
no estás en paz con vos mismo
como les decía al principio hay muchas
maneras de vivir cada uno podrá andar
por el camino que le parezca algunos
tenemos el privilegio de poder elegir de
tener varias oportunidades al alcance de
la mano tomar las de abandonar las
cuando creemos que nos vamos no va más
pero en esta vida elegir es un
privilegio enorme hay muchísima
muchísima más gente de la que pensamos
que tienen nuestras mismas capacidades
nuestra misma inteligencia y no tienen
la oportunidad de pararse un día y
elegir para dónde quieren ir
y eso es sumamente injusto
porque nadie acá se salva solo mi camino
independientemente de mis
particularidades de las capacidades que
fui teniendo es un camino que está lleno
de gente que me acompañó que me apoyó
que me formó que me contuvo cuando lo
necesite porque por sobre todas las
cosas nuestros caminos son caminos
compartidos
y ojalá que cumplir mandatos no nos siga
definiendo ni lo haga una carrera o lo
hago un trabajo y que si tenemos la
oportunidad de elegir que la
reconozcamos como un privilegio y la
honremos ejerciéndola
es muy difícil romper con lo que
aprendimos respecto a cómo vivir que
valorar y qué cosas son importantes pero
creo que es a lo que nos debemos si
queremos vivir honestamente la vida que
nos toca porque quizás así lleguemos
alguna vez a tener algo más que una
imagen feliz y podamos darle un real
contenido a esto que estamos viviendo
[Aplausos]